[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena seu
podcast semanal onde a gente dica troca
ideias sobre conteúdos que a gente leu
ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo uma visão
de produto PR discussão eu sou Artur e
pela primeira vez no programa quem tá
gripado sou eu eu sou a O Mundo Gira né
e vacilão
roda tem jogo do Brasil Dorival diola
começa a era Dorival diola a gente tá
gravando na segunda né na quarta-feira a
gente já vai saber que isso vai ser ruim
ou bom né já vamos tá triste né até
agora estamos tristes né porque do que
deu para ver até agora mas enfim no
programa de hoje a gente vai falar sobre
estratégias de ai quando faz sentido
integrar com mais de um modelo por onde
começar e coisas do tipo e vamos trazer
inclusive um
Deep Dive aí do que a Apple tá fazendo
com o ai também é isso mas antes de
falar de ai tem jabazinho da semana tem
curso de ai já vai começar puxar daí
sempre né tem aquele jabazinho essa
semana o patrão ficou maluco Então vai
ter é isso vai ter curso de pensamento
crítico e analítico comigo e com dudu
vai ter essa semana esse sábado agora
você vai estar escutando isso na
quarta-feira ainda vai vai ter dois dias
para você comprar a gente tá um mês e
meio avisando aqui né mas assim a gente
sabe que a galera gosta de comprar no
último minuto então assim a gente vai
dar uma uma brechinha aqui que o patrão
ficou maluco então assim normalmente o
desconto é de 15% aqui nos no na
descrição mas hoje somente essa semana
vai ter o desconto de 25% viu 1/4 do
preço aqui tá louco promoção de São João
festa junina promoção do São João
promoção da festa junina E então assim ó
dia 29/06 então esse sábado vai ser
online ao vivo e dia 6/07 que é o
próximo sábado vai ser presencial aqui
em São Paulo lá no escritório na casa da
PR carena no escritório da juus E aí ai
Lógico que tem um Ai também né Dia 20 de
julho daqui um mês então assim esse tem
tempo mas garante logo aí porque já tá
tá quase no terceiro lote Já o negócio
comigo efren a ikira vai tá lá também
Miriam também vai est lá Contando um
pouquinho das artimanhas de ai
então é isso aproveita o desconto Agora
sim bora lá pra pauta Bora
[Música]
lá bom a gente vai falar um pouquinho
aqui das estratégias de e sai um uma
matéria recente da Apple insider e eles
estavam falando sobre sobre bom a Apple
fez um acordo com com a Open ai para ter
o chat GPT integrado no iOS a gente já
falou disso no a dois episódios atrás se
você não assistiu não escutou ainda dá o
play lá mas um dos maiores mercados da
maçã é a China e lá não vai rolar de ter
uma empresa dos Estados Unidos Ainda
mais agora que a openi tem um cara que
era da NS no board né então
assim não sou uma empresa dos Estados
Unidos né uma empresa que o Core do
negócio é coleta e processamento de
dados né Pois é então eles estão em
negociações com a Baidu com a alibaba
mas não tem nada fechado só que é de
extrema importância para pra Apple o
Mercado Chinês então eles estão buscando
isso qual vai ser a outra qual vai ser a
empresa que vai estar por trás aí uma
vez que lá na China outras empresas já
estão com nos sistemas dela nativos
usando bastante ai e etc é a xiaomi e a
e a hiway né Principalmente pois é pois
é mas na real a gente trouxe essa
notícia assim para entrar um pouco mais
a fundo no quando a gente tá falando
sobre construção de produtos né
estratégia no final das contas e a
construção de produtos que tem ai por
trás fazer uns comentários aqui antes
sobre Apple ai e China porque a gente só
falou no programa da wwdc e já passaram
umas duas semanas assim né saí e saiu
bem mais informação Então acho que uma
coisa que a gente falou até no programa
da da Integração com openi que foi
ficando mais claro no nos nas dias
seguintes né era que na verdade boa
parte dos modelos são proprietários da
Apple eh a gente falou né das coisas que
iam rodar no device e o que vai rodar no
device são modelos proprietários o que
vai rodar nos servidores da Apple também
quando for necessário são modelos
proprietários E aí só em última
instância para casos mais que precis de
conhecimento eh mais do mundo real é que
eles vão usar os modulos da Open ai isso
disparou toda uma discussão na internet
de cara Quem tá ganhando o qu com isso
né porque se você pensar que o Google
paga algumas dezenas de bilhões por ano
paraa Apple para ser o buscador
principal ali né Open a princípio não tá
pagando nada pra Apple então tipo a Open
G ganha mais usuários ali né vamos dizer
mas não ganha dados para treinamento
então ficou essa dúvida e saiu uma
reportagem Hoje também que a Apple agora
tá conversando com a meta também para
colocar colocar as coisas lá também a
possibilidade de usar os modelos da Meta
Total parece muito um caminho assim que
eventualmente ela vai cobrar alguém para
ser o modelo principal E aí vai ser tipo
quando você abre o Safari isso depois de
anos que eles liberaram né você poder
selecionar Qual é o seu navegador padrão
ali então pode ser que seja um caminho
futuro ali talvez e um outro ponto só né
é que a gente tá muito acostumado a
falar das empresas do ocidente a gente
acaba não olhando muito pro pro Oriente
especificamente pra China né mas cara eh
recentemente tem tido pelo menos na
minha bolha no Twitter assim muito papo
sobre como a China Hoje é a maior
Potência em é produção científica do
mundo e principalmente os modelos de dei
todas essas grandes empresas né o Artur
falou do Baidu da alibaba que tão em
conversas aí com a Apple são modelos tão
competentes quanto os modelos principais
que a gente usa aqui no ocidente né
quando a gente olha PR pros bmk quando a
gente olha PR capacidades então eu vou
inclusive deixar aí um link no na
descrição de uma newsletter que eu
assino que ela é exclusivamente falando
sobre ai é na China então é é em inglês
né mas o cara traz artigos é em chinês
traduzidos e Mandarim né traduzidos
então dá para ter uma noção de tudo que
tá rolando por lá e eu acho bem
interessante para ficar por dentro do
que uma das duas maiores economias do
mundo está fazendo aí no negócio que é
tecnologia de ponta né E se você não
conseguir se você não não sabe ler em
mandarin joga no chat de GPT que ele
traduz para você ou depois que você
aprender lá você vai ver quais são as lá
da China e aí passa usar da China também
e já pede para ela mandar um translate
lá também mas enfim mais algum ponto aí
ô Aira acho que não bora falar de de
estratégia Pois é então no final das
contas isso me levou a a puxar muito
esse lance de por onde começar né como
criar como preparar os sistemas Pô o
quanto você vale a pena ser um alguma
coisa específica o quanto vale a pena
tipo já preparar o sistema para receber
várias Enfim acho que é um pouco um
pouco disso assim como o a falou a gente
fala muito sobre no no ocidente
principalmente se fala muito sobre o
chat ept e bem menos sobre outras como
Cloud Como o próprio o próprio do meta
mesmo né o lhama do meta apesar de vez
ou outra dar uma um barulho mas fala
pouco ainda de algumas de algumas outras
e a ideia é conversar um pouco sobre
isso assim e aí a comparação que eu
fiquei pensando aqui foi principalmente
na parte de Analytics assim porque a
gente já falou bastante aqui que ai tá
muito mais no como do que no no no de
fato no problem Space né é um Enabler né
exato exato e como podemos dizer é como
se fosse a ferramenta né a é meio que a
ferramenta assim e aí eu fiquei fazendo
uma algumas analogias que eu que eu
fiquei pensando que é um com mobile né
no aspecto de ah mobile com Android IOS
e etc depois os vários outras e
linguagens meio híbridas assim mas uma
outra que eu acho que serve muito para
esse contexto aqui que a gente vai falar
de pô como tá evoluindo muito rápido e
você fazer esse suit para uma coisa ou
outra que é ferramentas de Analytics
porque no passado você não tinha um
monte de de ferramentas né você tinha o
Google Analytics lá era o default né
integrava o default lá e se você eh
usava aplicativo se Provavelmente você
tinha implementado o Fire base lá antes
do Google comprar e etc e depois todas
as coisas lá e depois acabou voltando
pro Google Analytics do mesmo saudade do
meu crash litic crash litic como que
chamava era Fabri er Fabric Fabric
saudoso Fabric que primeiro foi pro
twitter né o Twitter comprou primeiro
depois C comprou você lembra disso Car
moleque é mas enfim e aí falando dessa
comparação era isso Então Pô Beleza você
vai você vai implementar uma outra
ferramenta Cara você não precisava ficar
fazendo esse Switch né Toda hora ah não
agora meus dados vão est lá se você
tivesse uma estrutura muito bem
consolidada de dados Pode ser que você
tinha umas Pode ser que você tinha o
Google Analytics e eu mandava os seus
dados para uma outra para ter ali o
Double check eu mandava direto pro seu
dat Lake alguma coisa do tipo ass Esse
aí é o Esse aí é o é o top velho manda
tem ter a ferramenta mas mandar também
pro dat Lake para depois cruzar com
transacional é E aí depois começou a
surgir outras ferramentas né tipo
segment ah que fazia ali a camada
intermediária Então você podia plugar em
quantos analíticas se você quisesse Mas
enfim não era uma coisa assim que quando
você ia desolver você pô beleza vou ter
várias analíticas aqui para para fazer o
sutch quando eu precisasse até porque é
uma duplicação de trabalho né tipo
imagina que eu vou mandar evento pro
firebase pro Mix panel e pro amplitude
são três sdc para você implementar
aí você vai eventualmente cair no
cenário onde nenhum número Bate com
outro e aí você vai ficar querendo
escovar bit para achar o número mais
certo não era produtivo de Fato né não
era não era E aí quando a gente fala um
pouco do mundo atual de ai o jogo muda
bastante né e acho que a principal coisa
para mim que muda é ael idade que os
modelos estão evoluindo Total E aí
quando os modelos estão evoluindo muito
você fala assim tá bom eu vou ficar vou
usar até a sua expressão vou ficar
enxugando o bit aqui para deixar ele
mega no no que eu preciso e pode ser que
você vai ter casos onde que você vai
muito mais para essa parte mesmo de usar
modelos específicos né e desenvolver
modelos específicos e aprimorar os
modelos versus o usar os genéricos e
quando você entra nessa parte do usar os
genéricos as os próprios se você parar
pensar nas próprias pu chat GPT assim
por exemplo a Open ai ela tem vários
modelos ali que ela deixa você usar de
acordo com o que você paga né É então
ela tem lá o o 3.5 tem o for0 tem eu não
sei o que é a gente não fala muito aqui
né mas porque a gente fala mais do
negócio que é que é user Face sim mas
dentro das apis tem diversas apis
diferentes para modelos diferentes para
funcionalidades diferentes lá e com o
tempo eles vão até deprec uma ou outra
ou adicionando funcionalidade mas para
quem faz as chamadas direto paraas api
já já consegue ter mais visibilidade
disso né sim é mas eu até no próprio
customer facing mesmo de você pode lá
selecionar né Qual que é o qual o modelo
você quer e aí eu acho que entra muito
nessa discussão assim o quanto o quanto
hoje já né o quanto hoje já pensar que
em 2022 que foi quando a open a o shpt
foi lançado né o quanto que passou sei
lá menos de 2 anos e o quanto que a
gente consegue já assim os modelos estão
evoluindo tão rápido que pô é muito mais
fácil você preparar a estrutura dos seus
do seu produto né que vai utilizar ai
podendo fazer sutch para vários modelos
diferentes de empresas diferentes
contextos diferentes que vão ter valores
diferentes também né preços diferentes e
adaptar ele por que que fizer mais
sentido pro seu contexto né Total eu
acho que teve um momento Inicial ali
tipo da logo no chat chpt mesmo e tal
que era aquela parada completamente nova
com capacidades completamente não vistas
antes e que cara todo mundo queria
experimentar o que dava para fazer o que
não dava para fazer e não tinha
concorrência na época de Fato né era um
modelo to ru and all né então fazia
total sentido você fazer um negócio
muito específico travado PR opf não
tinha opção né eu acho que agora quase
do anos depois ali Acho que a gente tem
uma clareza muito boa de que isso vai
vir isso é commodity os modelos são
commodity de certa forma você vai ter n
modelos fornecidos por n empresas e que
eu tendo a achar que em algum momento
vai se estabilizar aqui a diferença
entre eles né não vai ter diferenças
super altas ess semana a gente vai falar
depois mas saiu o modelo novo da
antropic e ele bate o GPT for0 em em
alguns marqu né então acho que ho já tá
claro que vão existir diversos modelos
de empresas diferentes e aí eu entro
Entra muito naquela coisa de fornecedor
de serviço mesmo do que é Core e do que
não é Core da sua empresa né porque o
que é Core se você tem um você não tem
nenhum se você tem dois você tem um Era
um negócio que a gente falava muito lá
na época do Esporte Interativo na época
depois você já tinha saído que eu tava
olhando muito pra operação de streaming
que cara pro streaming eu não podia ter
um um cara só fornecendo não podia ter
um fornecedor só de CDN por exemplo
porque se a camai e cai por algum
motivo eu tenho que ter outra para
servir porque aquele jogo tá acontecendo
ao vivo naquele momento né então a real
que a gente tinha quatro cdns diferentes
e a gente fazia o intercâmbio ali
olhando pô qual CDN serve melhor tal
lugar então a gente tinha um
público no nordeste tinha uma CDN
específica que servia melhor lá como que
a gente faz o melhor balanceamento de
custo entre as cdns que a gente tem aqui
entra confiança e os modelos de ai estão
caminhando para isso e vão cada vez mais
ser na minha opinião isso de você vai
ter modelos que são bons para coisas
específicas que você vai usar em
determinadas eh tarefas você vai ter
modelo de custos diferentes que você
também vai usar em determinadas tarefas
então a gente começou numa época onde
era muito caro vamos dizer assim e fazia
muito sentido você usar um modelo Só
porque não tinha opções e porque você
estava entendendo os modelos e a gente
tá entrando numa frase numa fase de
otimização por mais maluco que isso
possa parecer dado que tudo tem mudado
tão rápido né mas é igual Startup que
você enfia um monte de gente para
crescer e tal e depois você vai
otimizando os processos e estrutura eu
acho que a gente tá bem nessa fase com
com inteligência artificial e faz total
sentido você ser de certa forma
agnóstico para você plugar o que for
melhor e e o que fizer mais sentido para
aquele contexto é e nessa nessa linha de
plugar que fizer mais sentido pro
contexto é isso né entender de fato o
que que é o Core então assim pô beleza
no Core eu vou precisar de ter modelos
específicos fazendo até uma uma
comparação assim hoje no meu contexto na
docket cara o Google ele não vai ficar
especialista numa matrícula de móvel tá
ligado o document ai não vai ficar
especialista numa matrícula de móvel
então assim só que tipo ele vai ter ter
uma série de outros modelos lá que
servem para n tipos de documentos de
forma mais prática Então beleza agora
você precisar de uma análise bem
detalhada que vai ganhar seu tempo pô
provavelmente a docket vai fazer isso
melhor porque a gente tá especializado
nisso né a gente criou modelos
específicos para para isso e para vários
outros tipos de documento também só que
também a gente fica pensando que é tá a
gente criou um modelo um modelo que
antes dele ser especialista Ele É
genérico né para ele entender documentos
no nosso Pipe e tudo mais então assim pô
por não usar ele também para outros
tipos de documentos que são mais
padronizados e etc e etc né então acho
que entra muito nessa discussão de
estratégia mesmo por isso que a gente
até falou de de como estratégia Qual que
é a estratégia a gente optou pelo
contrário de pelo mais específico para
depois ir pro genérico mas quantas
outras também não fizeram o contrário né
foram primeiro pro genérico antes de ir
de fato pro específico né é e é difícil
tomar essa decisão nessa quadra da
história em que a gente está Porque você
não sabe o quanto esses modelos vão
ficar bons o suficiente para mesmo
coisas específicas mas que não são tipo
muito muito muito específicas eles serem
guren off sabe então às vezes tipo é o
famoso 8020 né o Pareto Às vezes você
vai ter um modelo genérico da Open a que
para 80% dos casos mesmo no domínio de
documentos
eh burocráticos da docket ele vai
funcionar muito bem e esse vai ter o 20%
que ele não vai ser tão bom que você vai
usar outros modelos eh proprietários que
são mais caros mas ainda assim para
esses domínios específico É muito
difícil você saber cara será que isso
aqui vai ficar bom o suficiente para
isso né e ou não porque os próprios
caras da Open ai falam isso né cara hoje
Muitas das coisas dos produtos que são
GPT rappers aqui vão morrer com a
evolução do próprio modelo sabe até onde
o modelo vai ficar tão bom para ser tão
genérica até onde vai existir
especialização né Pois é e por isso que
eu acho mais mais uma vez é importante o
lance de conseguir ter uma estrutura
preparada para fazer o sutch de seja de
modelo seja específico seja de genérico
ou que quer que seja né que entra nisso
dependendo do momento e isso impacta até
o tipo de profissional que você vai
precisar contratar né pro seu time
também não total e enquanto eu falava
aqui eu fiquei pensando até em Adi né em
artificial General intell inteligência
que é a galera fala ah mas quando
atingir a idar e os modelos vão ter
capacidade de raciocínio como humano e
tal e mesmo quando a gente chegar lá
cara pensa que todo ser humano tem um
certo nível de inteligência né ainda
assim existem especializações né Eh tem
seres humanos que são especializados em
medicina tem seres humanos que são
especializados em tecnologia né então
Sei lá talvez a a a também mesmo quando
a gente chegar lá ela vai ter um nível
de inteligência humano Médio Mas para
tarefas específicas Você ainda vai
precisar de uma especialização dos
modelos né Então você vai ter uma
inteligência geral artificial que é
muito boa então um mano médico consegue
pegar um documento um contrato ler e
entender por alto que aquilo é um
contrato de que que tá falando e tal mas
você vai precisar de um modelo
específico que saiba criar contratos com
base em lei xpto que funcionem
jurisdições tal e que proteam as partes
Y então mesmo quando a gente chegar em
adi é é muito capaz que ainda assim vão
existir essas discussões de que que eu
faço no modelo genérico Edi e que que eu
faço no modelo específico né e e até
dentro do cenário da docker só para
falar Tipo o ouro não é o modelo né o
ouro é o dado é o ouro é a parada que só
você tem acesso no fim que é o que volta
pro que eu falei lá no início que os
modelos eles vão ser commodity então
Todo mundo vai ter acesso ao mesmo
modelo nem todo mundo vai ter acesso a a
dados para treinar esse modelo da melhor
forma total que é um pouquinho inclusive
que a própria Open ai fez isso e o
Facebook tem isso de milhão de bilhão
também e etc que é a as parcerias né a
Open ai fez com o Reddit lá o Facebook
tem com seus bilhões de usuários que é é
o dado né que é o dado que vai ser o
rico para ajudar que a gente até falou
no no episódio lá né da mudança do do
aspecto de de ads né No final das contas
mesmo no no mundo tem toda parada de
dados sintéticos também que tá uma uma
baita conversa assim de não temos mais
dados suficientes criados por humanos
como que a gente treina esses modelos
com os próprios modelos gerando eh seus
dados né E aí é algo que sempre se
discutiu em em machine learning de certa
forma de mesmo antes dessa onda de Ai
que é o garb de in garb de Out né então
se você gera dado lixo na entrada você
vai gerar dado lixo na saída se você tem
modelo gerando dados de baixa qualidade
os output desses modelos vão ser de
baixa qualidade também é isso mas no
final das contas acho pra gente fechar o
bloco aqui que ho gente foi meio nerdola
esse bloco aqui hein foi levemente
nerdola levemente nerdola selo nerdola
de de análises aqui mas acho fazendo um
repap aqui no final das contas é na sua
estratégia se seu produto vai ter ai e
se você tá desenvolvendo um produto que
depende de ai ou que precisa de ai ali
para facilitar alguma coisa que alguns
pontos que são interessantes para você
analisar primeiro é o quanto de fato
você precisa de modelos especialistas e
o outro é preparar suu stack para você
conseguir fazer esse Switch para
múltiplos modelos seja puxar para Open
ai para pro Gini pro Cloud para qualquer
outra que aparecer e que isso seja com o
menor esforço possível né porque se Toda
vez você precisar ficar desenvolvendo
maior tempão para adicionar mais uma
cara Provavelmente você vai você já tá
atrás né na velocidade que o negócio
surge Você já se fu exato É e aí eu acho
também outras coisas que é três itens
assim para pensar sempre né integração a
velocidade né de E aí dos modelos e tudo
mais e o custo com isso assim você já
tem uma boa fórmula aí para entender e
ver o que que vai fazer sentido pro seu
contexto meu e voltando lá atrás no que
você falou é lembrar que isso é mais uma
ferramenta não é o fazer ai por fazer ai
então entender o impacto na experiência
do produto mesmo que você tá cuidando né
quando quando o Artur fala de velocidade
ali tem a velocidade de desenvolvimento
mas tem a velocidade dos outputs dos
tokens pro seu usuário ali então
faz sentido teu usuário esperar 20
segundos para receber um um output ali
porque às vezes isso vai driv a sua
decisão porque às vezes você pode ter um
modelo melhor mas que demora mais mas
que faz sentido para aquele caso Ou você
tem alguma constante de custo por
exemplo Então você pô para um negócio
que é muito simples será que eu deveria
estar usando o modelo mais top de linha
que é o mais caro do mercado de fato
Então como que você faz para dentro do
teu produto tá pegando esses inputs do
teu usuário né então o input da
qualidade do output do modelo né então
vamos supor o caso de uso mais clássico
aqui e que tá na cabeça de todo mundo
que é para atendimento né suporte vamos
dizer assim pô como é que você pega
depois no final no com cesat com alguma
coisa que aquele atendimento foi bom de
fato e e como que você retroalimenta
isso eh e aí internamente Como que você
entende os custos disso né então não é
só igual
época da das vacas gordas Startup que
você sai usando as coisas nem olha o
custo né então como é que você balanceia
o custo e como que você entende e aí é
parte do que a gente traz aqui toda
semana né E que a gente curte de
compartilhar as novidades que é que que
tá saindo de novo ou o que que tá sendo
melhor desenvolvido pro que você precisa
então dá o exemplo a gente vai falar do
de novo trazendo o modelo novo da
antropic o o cloud 3.5 sonit ou sonet
acho que é sonet ele já era um modelo
que eu via muitos das newsletters que eu
assino falando cara esse é o modelo
superior para ajudar em atividad de
escrita ele é muito melhor do que os
modelos da Open ai para isso
operatividade criativa e tal e aí agora
a galera tá fazendo a mesma coisa
falando pô esse modelo novo ele é melhor
em código do que os modelos da Open A
então como tá saindo coisa nova o tempo
todo como é que você também se cerca
dessas informações para saber Pô esse
modelo novo é melhor para isso como que
você faz as suas próprias avaliações né
então tem tem toda uma disciplina
acadêmica de avaliação de modelos mas
também tem a parte do você usar seu
usuário usar e te dar feedback então
muita coisa para considerar ali e de
novo flexibilidade no momento onde as
coisas andam muito rápido pode salvar
vidas né exatamente E assim se você
quiser saber mais ainda os behind the
scenes de construir produto que tem ai
não esqueça patrão ficou maluco tem 25%
de desconto no link da descrição e no
dia 20 de julho vai ter mais uma edição
do curso de ai para PMs hein
esse foi o anúncio contextualizado né
targeted que o cara que ficou até aqui
ouvindo ele tem interesse no assunto né
minimamente ouvindo a gente falando a
meia hora
[Música]
aqui e a vamos aproveitar vamos falar
mais de ai vamos a gente já nem falou né
cara vamos fazer esse programa dedicado
e vamos fazer uma rodadinha de Notícias
aí do que aconteceu nos últimos dias vai
manda ver cara primeira coisa é empresa
Nova de a openis né Toda semana tem uma
dessa vez o o willam sever que foi o
é a mente porás nás
saída do Sama do Game of Thrones ele
fundou uma empresa nova né que é a ssi
Safe super intelligence e cara
basicamente é mais uma empresa de ai só
que ele diz que não vai ter um produto
consumer facing que eles vão estar
focados em segurança em atingir
Adi para mim é mais um um Lab de
pesquisa né Os caras estão fazendo é um
láb é o que eles queriam fazer na Open a
Open virou outra coisa E aí eles fizeram
um lá com certeza vão conseguir um
funding legal para isso e cara quanto
mais gente trabalhando no domínio melhor
essa é a real é isso mas teve uma frase
ali que eu senti uma pitadinha de uma
indireta pro pra Open a foi né que eles
falaram que
a ssi é a nossa missão é o nosso nome e
é o nosso Road map porque esse é o nosso
foco nosso time nosso investidores e
nosso modelo nosso modelo de negócio tá
alinhado para atingir uma Safe super
inteligence Então assim tá escrito aí ó
Road map todo produtor sabe que o Road
map tá aí Para quê Para ser mudado então
então não dá para confiar em nada disso
daqui que mais que a gente tem de
Notícias pô a Open Essa é fresquinha né
quer dizer é fresquinha hoje na segunda
que a gente tá gravando mas a Open com
comprou mais uma empresa agora né é a
qual que é o nome mesmo é
a Multi que antes chamava remotion
remotion e eles tinham comprado uma
outra empresa dia desse uns três dias
atrás a Rock ro é rock exat rock set
Rock City É acho que é Rock Set mas é
então dinheiro em caixa é bom né dá para
ir comprando os outros e esse da Mult
especificamente pelo que falaram foi um
aquire né já o da Rock 7 ali era uma uma
plataforma de indexação de conteúdo né E
de de informação Real Time Eu vi até
algumas pessoas falando Ah tem todo
cheiro de tecnologia para fazer algo
parecido com o Recall da Microsoft no
Windows né e e tem toda uma pegada
também de enterprise de de ofertas de
soluções enterprise veremos que mais
cara falamos para car eu falei pelo
menos algumas vezes né mas do novo
modelo antropic aqui o cloud 3.5 sonet
então não sei se tem muito além para
falar mas é um modelo novo que bateu o
GPT 4 for acho que a notícia é essa né o
barulho que foi foi porque pela primeira
vez o modelo passou o for agora e tal
exato e cara é triste porque essa
os modelos do antropic não são
acessíveis no Brasil né dá para você
acessar via po mas não dá para você
acessar de diretamente ali e é o que eu
comentei vários dos caras que eu leio
assim falando que pô continua muito bom
eh principalmente para atividades de
escrita e de código teve um negócio que
eu achei bem interessante que é o
artifacts que é uma ferramenta que eles
lançaram ali como Beta junto com o
modelo que ele é meio que um workspace
junto ali da da interface de chat E aí
acho que o jeito mais procurem no
Twitter e tal no YouTube para ter uma
visão né mas acho que o mais legal é na
parte de código por exemplo que você
você consegue interagir com o código que
ele tá gerando então tem vários casos de
tipo mais clássico as pessoas pedindo
para construir um jogo né seja o Snake o
clássico jogo da cobrinha teve um cara
que fez um protótipo de Doom com fases
ali geradas artificialmente né e com o
chat ept por exemplo você precisaria
copiar aquele código jogar no no no vs
code da vida compilar rodar ali não tá
rodando direto você consegue interagir e
isso ajuda até no no processo de você
iterar em cima do código né então tem
isso e e tem questão de custo também eu
acho que eu cheguei a ver uns tweets de
que ele chegava a ser quatro cinco vezes
mais barato que que o modelo da openi
Então volta pro que a gente falou ali de
custos né pode ser uma B opção aí tá
disponível em alguns vendors tá na
Amazon se eu não me engano acho que tá
disponível via Google Cloud também então
é é isso e acho que para fechar aqui a o
giro de notícias é uma notícia simples
mas é a Apple tem o programa Apple
developer Academy né E eles agora eles
incluíram a parte de ai também inclusive
vai vir pro Brasil enfim eu acho que é
vai ser no segundo semestre agora e Pô
eu acho que o interessante disso é no
afal das contas pra Apple é bom ter mais
por isso que ela criou esse programa né
ter mais pessoas desenvolvendo desde
cedo na plataforma dela mas acho que
essa é uma outra porta que eles abriram
já desde cedo né que é eu mostro o
quanto que eles estão interessados nesse
nesse contexto de ai então eles vão não
só ensinar as tecnologias de pra né de
como codar no Swift coisas do tipo mas
também já aprender sobre ai é
[Música]
isso então vamos lá pros produtos da
semana que tem tempo que a gente não
falava né temo tempo que a gente não
fala então começa aí já que você já
falou começa aí qual que é o seu produto
da semana Pô cara meu produto da semana
tá sendo app gravidez mais Olha aí é
cara papai Artur mesmo né papai Artur né
cara porque ele é muito é um app muito
legal é um app da Philips Mas ele é
muito legal que dá pr você é cara mas
mas dá pr você pô acompanhar em que como
que tá o que que é esperado da semana
que que a tá acontecendo Qual que é o
tamanho que o que o bebê tá aí você pode
selecionar lá você quer ver o tamanho
dele se ele fosse uma fruta se ele fosse
um animal eu já vi vários prints desse
app na internet velho agora eu eu abri
aqui para ver Car é muito legal é muito
legal e mas eu vou fazer uma menção
horrosa aqui por um que eu já falei
algumas vezes que é o riban meta né Pô
cara eles lançaram uma atualização essa
semana que agora
uma das coisas que eu falei bastante
também já que é os vídeos serem maiores
né ter a possibilidade de gravar vídeos
agora os vídeos podem ser de até TR
minutos então já é um já é melhor né não
que você vai ficar fazendo vídeo de 3
minutos o tempo todo mas pô já diminui
mesmo você tem que ficar a cada um
minuto apertando o botãozinho lá né já é
legal então cara Sou suspeito para dizer
mas tem acompanhado desde sempre mas tá
sendo muito assim como a Open a e as
ferramentas Dei no geral a galera do do
riban também tá trabalhando porque cara
Vira e Mexe só esse ano tanto de updates
que eles já lançaram assim o negócio tá
tá evoluindo você postou lá no no link
Disney e o Marcel até comentou
comemorar feature de salvar o negócio no
celular automaticamente é brincadeira
também né Tá arrancando feature para
depois botar o básico o pessoal lá do
Facebook mas é aquela parada é o básico
brilhante né cara
eu achei bom ess esse o comentário do do
Marcel lá no seu push porque eu fiquei
pensando aqui o negócio que a gente tem
que considerar né como pessoas de
produto que cara que que é o essencial
para isso daqui sair e se você pensar
salvar o negócio automaticamente não é
essencial de fato é um é uma melhoria
improvement of Life ali mas não é
essencial Então faz total sentido você
não fazer isso de cara e fazer depois
sabe não é igual no início você tinha
que est com o celular aberto ó o
aplicativo aberto para fazer o o pad das
fotos agora já não não precisa mais de
novo é um negócio pode parecer muito
simples mas na no dia a dia na
experiência muda tudo né E é difícil
fazer essas escolhas do que é essencial
n a Alice que foi Nossa convidada na
edição passada do prct Hero quem não
ouviu ainda ouve é um negócio que ela
provocava muito assim de tipo tá mas
isso é realmente necessário tipo a a
pessoa não consegue usar o que a gente
quer entregar de valor se não tiver isso
isso faz a gente refletir de Ah talvez
não seja de fato é isso E você qual foi
o seu o meu é um dois em um que é o
mesmo mesma empresa mesmo produto que é
o Buscapé barra Zoom aí então eu tô de
mudança né E aí tô comprando coisa para
casa né eletrodoméstico móvel essas
coisas e cara o Buscapé e o zoom tem
sido uma mão na roda assim não só para
comparar preço ali e entre as dierentes
lojas mas para ver o histórico de preço
né então cara tem coisas que você não tá
acostumado a comprar então tipo cara não
sei H quantos anos eu comprei uma
geladeira então não tô muito ligado na
tendência de presão da geladeira para
abrir o a Amazon e ver e saber se aquilo
tá barato ou caro né e é muito legal que
eles dão lá uma tendência pô de preço
nos últimos 40 dias últimos 60 dias
últimos 3 meses então isso ajuda para
caramba e eles T outra coisa também que
é cashback então eles T cashbacks ali em
lojas específicas até bem bons então
estava com 15% de cashback na loja da LG
por exemplo eh ontem então tem ajudado
para caramba aqui na nas compras da casa
nova muito bom tô esperando convite pro
Open House aí hein deixa eu mudar
primeiro velho Deixa eu me assentar
primeiro bom os ouvintes aqui nossos
ouvintes sempre mandaram o Cloves mandou
o invisibel ai que é basicamente um um
negocinho lá que você coloca um
aplicativo pro Mac para você também
conversar com o Mac e ele fazer é o x
GPT Mas enfim sem ser o x GPT é o GPT
rapper é a Nana mandou o canva a Miria
mandou o iFood mas especificamente a
feature de mostrar a lista do mercado
que é do tipo di que eu acho que outra
pessoa já mandou isso outra vez é eu não
me recordo agora mas eu também não tenho
tenho essa leve lembrança a Karina
mandou a o connect da Garmim que também
já mandaram aqui outras vezes o Eduardo
mandou o r Stúdio ou R Studio eh para
quem Coda lá nas nessas linguagens
diferenciadas o Bob mandou o Spotify e
ele falou que depois do WhatsApp foi o
melhor o aplicativo o melhor aplicativo
já inventado na história é o dinheiro é
o dinheiro que eu já falei isso aqui que
eu pago mais tranquilo de mensalidade
por mês é o meu Spotify velho eu também
eu também isso até você falou de pagar
eu até lembrei Você lembra quando o
WhatsApp começou que ele custava R 1
lembro na época do iPhone 99 Cent é 99
cents caraca moleque Eu lembro que eu
peguei uma vez eu tinha um Iphone 3G na
época isso era 2011 E aí eles deixaram
grátis uma vez assim na época a eu
peguei naquela época e foi isso boa o
Glauco mandou o HBO Max falou que ele só
que agora não é mais HBO né É só Maxx e
e ele falou que ele só baixou de novo
para assistir o House of Dragon tá pouco
hypado hein inclusive of Dragon flopando
é e o Lucas mandou o bipa que é um um
aplicativo para você comprar e é
especificamente a feature de compra
recorrente de Bitcoin enfim galera cara
do cripto né a gente a gente quase não
fala de cripto aqui no programa né Eu
sou po não a gente já tá falando de ai
bastante é o ass é o h o r do momento tá
bom a gente tá falando de algo que tem
utilidade de Fato
né é esse meu comentário sobre cripto
então com essa com essa a gente parte
para encerrar o programa né é
[Música]
isso
Ah então é isso com isso a gente encerra
mais uma edição aqui do papo na arena
recadinhos de sempre não se esqueçam de
lá dar cinco estrelas é seguir a gente
seja onde quer que você usa podcasts
YouTube subsc Spotify Apple podcast
qualquer lugar vai lá segue a gente para
você ser avisado toda vez que sair um
podcast novo e ó interage nas enquetes
que a gente posta lá a gente bota
enquete no Spotify né Principalmente Mas
mesmo se você não ouviu por lá você pode
votar porque a gente falou no programa
anterior que a gente ia trazer aqui o
resultado da enquete eu fui olhar hoje
não só tinha uma resposta na enquete
então vocês não estão interagindo nas
enquetes
enquanto não tiver interação a gente não
vai trazer interajam nas enquetes A
gente vai pensar aqui qual que vai ser a
enquete de hoje porque eu não tô pronto
PR dizer agora qual será se Sorta teu na
cabeça não vamos a pode perguntar se as
pessoas estão usando algum outro modelo
além do é isso boa boa a gente bota umas
opções lá você tem usado com frequência
algum outro modelo seja o
j o próprio Cloud enfim tem as opções aí
e Sigam a gente lá nas redes né @x @ur
close comk no Instagram no Twitter no
trads no Linkedin e aonde estamos
hospedados @ product Arena também aí em
todas as redes e semana que vem tem mais
né Artur semana que vem tem mais Espero
não estar com a voz estranha anasalada
anasalada
e semana que vem a gente volta aí eu
falo qual que é a fruta
o doce da semana que toda semana se trás
é exato que a i minha filha cham A I A
gente já decidiu o nome então vou falar
toda semana agora qual que é o tamanho
dela fechou até semana que vem Valeu
Valeu galera